And the Djs no longer picked their own records.
Program directors picked the records.
Okay.
And it became very specific target demo.
We want a home in and whatever.
And keep in mind when Howard stern left regular radio,
terrestrial radio for the stratosphere,
I got his job in New York City.
Oh,
that's right.
I was broadcasting in seven different cities.
I forgot you did that.
Okay.
Dallas,
New York,
Philly,
I think I was in and Cetera,
cetera.
And it turns out,
I think what they wanted was a version of Howard Stern.
Okay,
great.
I'll be a third class.
Howard stern or a first class David Lee.
My approach to it is very different than his would be.
We're two very different people.
Um,
he's talking,
he's a personality.
It's all about interaction.
I see myself as show people.
I'm music first.
Okay.
So the first thing I'm going to pick when we throw a barbecue is not the food or
the guest list,
but what's the music?
Right.
Well,
white people listen to Bob Marley when we're on vacation and when we celebrate
things,
we listened to Kool and the gang.
Right?
Right.
And I would play those and the ratings were going up and they were pissing off
management really well.
They said we feel that Leonard Skinner to Nickelback are more appropriate for
your audience.
So the ratings were going up and they were upset?
Yes.
And because you couldn't rein me in.
Okay.
Now keep in mind I hired cooling the ganged open for van Halen tour before last.
You have never seen so many people dancing in one place.
That's the sound of every wedding.
Bar Mitzvah from Bachelor party cause this is ladies night and the fees awarded
I and you've got to sing that.
Look at each other as you're driving like whoa.
Dot.
What did they say to you before you took the job?
Like what was the,
what was the conversation when you agreed to do it?
What did you think was going to happen as opposed to what did happen?
Well,
what you say and what is real.
Yeah,
that's the problem right now.
I,
we've discussed doing commercials for example,
and I don't feel comfortable doing commercials unless it's something I actually
use,
you know,
like sunglasses or cigarettes.
Right.
Beyond that.
I know
Vermont tear bear kind of a thing.
I don't know.
Right.
So it was uncomfortable from the beginning.
I got fired for playing too much ethnic music and uh,
for late night humor too early in the morning.
But that was Howard Stern's whole deals.
Late nine.
Humor.
No,
it's not.
It's a different kind of humor.
What was your deal as opposed to his,
well,
whenever we brought on porn,
stars actually knew him.
There were no died.
I,
we'd already gone through.
They're getting to know you phase seasons earlier,
kind of you to do all talk or did they want you to play music as well as my
sense of humor is different,
unique as you,
as is his and as is yours.
Okay.
You can't eat.
We have old league of imitations in our end of the business in broadcasting.
Okay.
But,
um,
there's no snare drum and high hat,
nor is there for Howard.
You follow?
Um,
he very,
again,
I start with the music.
I start with the ambiance and if humor arises or personalities or rise or we
have guests,
great.
If we don't,
that's fine too.
Um,
uh,
and I think they expected other,
what I showed up with was it also ranged.
Uh,
it wasn't always funny.
Hmm.
Okay.
Do you think that it was just maybe something you would have excelled at if they
had different expectations?
Like instead of following Howard Stern,
they just did the David Lee you,
yeah.
Do you think you'd still be doing it?
Uh,
yes.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Their expectations was the funny,
the funny interview.
The guests have pop culture,
funny guests and the subject matter,
just as we've touched on subjects here that are hilarious and subjects that are
pretty dense.
Yeah.
As I call it,
you know,
it's going to detonate halfway down the turnpike.
Oh,
that's what he fucking meant.
It's not stuff that's going to go away real quick.
Do you
about doing that now?
Like what if apple came to you or one of these streaming services came to you
and wanted to do something like that?
They always arrive with expectations
and the expectations,
uh,
just as we discussed the three phases of Anna Nicole Smith and Elvis.
Yeah.
Which Dave are you referring to?
Well,
I just think you just with someone like you,
I mean I'm not a program director,
but if I was,
I would say just let him be him.
Just figure it out.
Just let it give it time to grow.
That's why people don't do they metal,
the metal they like you're going to do.
I look from what I know of you,
you're going to do your best at everything.
Everything you do,
you're going to do your best.
If I was going to hire you,
that's what I would say.
Everybody get the fuck away from him.
He's going to do his best now let them hire who he wants to hire and do what he
wants to do and put what he wants to put on and let him figure it out.
But you hired David Lee Roth.
He didn't hire Mike Fitzgerald and and and can Buchanan whatever the fuck the
other people are that work in the office.
It also wants to ges in the soup.
No,
you hired David Lee Roth.
Let David Lee Roth Be David Lee Roth and let him find his legs.
A difficult entity because it comes with a lot of history.
Yeah.
You know,
and then the people will start,
folks will start conducting,
well,
you gotta play this.
Yeah.
I got a play.
And it has very specific expectations.
Usually.